today on the Matt Walsh show president
Trump yesterday compared the coronavirus
to car accidents and he's been mocked
and derided for this comparison but I
think people are missing the very
important ethical point that Trump was
trying to raise the media especially
missing the point as they usually do
with with President Trump intentionally
of course so we're gonna take a deep
dive into this ethical point that Trump
was raising was I think it's important
and we'll talk about that today also
five headlines including Nancy Pelosi
and Joe Biden both in separate TV
interview is about the virus babbling
nonsensically at least to me it seems to
be it seems like they're just babbling
nonsensically but I'll play the clips
and I mean you tell me if you can make
heads or tails of it and today well
we'll cancel a feminist lawmaker who
thinks that the corona virus is
essentially a weapon of the patriarchy
because of course everything with
feminists everything is about them
including the corona virus and that is
obviously stupid for a number of reasons
and we'll get into all of that today but
first before we go any more further I
want to tell you about our friends over
at stamps.com
you know I think it's always good to
avoid the post office if you can because
of the lines because of the crowds and
everything else especially these days I
think we're all we're all looking for
ways to to avoid the post office and
that's where stamps.com comes in you
know but but the question is what if you
need to mail something what if you have
needs where you would usually go to the
post office for that what if you need
postage to send out letters and packages
whatever the case may be well don't
worry stamps comm is here to help how
well anything you can do at the post
office
you can do at stamps comments that
simple prints postage on demand you can
skip those lines and the crowd at the
post office which again these days I
think we're all looking to do here at
daily wire you know we've been using
stamps calm since 2017 and that means
that we've saved a whole lot of time and
saving time also means saving money
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready you just leave it for your mail
carrier or you could schedule a free
pickup package pick up drop it in the
mailbox
whatever it is no human contact required
it's that
simple right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Walsh tat stamps comm enter
Walsh stay safe out there
alright President Trump as I said
getting a lot of grief for a point he
made during a virtual Town Hall on Fox
News and answering a question about his
contention that the shutdown should come
to an end
relatively soon Trump returned to a an
analogy that he's certainly not the
first person to raise this but so it's
somewhat familiar but I think it's
important so listen to this
I brought some numbers here will is
thousands and thousands of people a year
to the flu we don't turn the country off
I mean every year now when I heard the
number you know we average 37,000 people
here can you believe that and actually
this year we're having a bad flu season
but we lose thousands of people a year
to the flu we never turned the country
off we lose much more than that to
automobile accidents we didn't call up
the automobile companies say stop making
cars we don't want any cars anymore
we have to get back to work and then
comes the screaming headlines and the
outraged tweets and everything else as
we have come to expect in editorial in
the Washington Post takes Trump to task
for for this analogy a bad analogy the
Washington Post says and the the article
argues that car accidents and the
coronavirus are not the same because
diseases are transmissible whereas car
accidents are not and their death rates
can grow exponentially where you don't
find that with car accidents and this
seems to be the standard response to
this analogy where we're told we cannot
make these kinds of comparisons because
two very different things cannot be
compared in this way well first of all
not to focus too much on the semantics
of this but comparisons are in fact only
valid when they are made between two
different things
comparing the corona virus to the corona
virus would be rather redundant and
probably unhelpful and I blame the I
think I've complained about this before
the
apples and oranges phrase that I blame
that for people don't understand what a
comparison is and so you when someone
wants to say that a comparison is
invalid they say oh that's like
comparing apples and oranges what are
you talking about you can compare apples
and oranges in a million different ways
that's a perfectly valid comparison
between apples and oranges the fact that
they're different is what makes what is
what makes you able to compare them now
it's true that nothing that is not the
coronavirus is exactly like the
coronavirus but we could still pull from
our experience dealing with other deadly
problems in order to inform our efforts
in dealing with this one but more to the
point the response from the Washington
Post and others misses the basic point
that the analogy seems to be trying to
make Trump was not suggesting that we
handle the coronavirus like we handle
car accidents or that the two things are
similar in any sort of practical way
this rather I think is a point about the
ethical dilemma at work here so about
35,000 people died in car accidents
every year in this country many more are
maimed and crippled I don't know what
that number is but we know that it's
many more it's many many times more than
35,000 and that works out to just
looking at the fatality rate that's
about a hundred people dead per day half
of them under the age of 50 so this is a
problem that affects especially the
young globally the yearly death toll is
a million more than a million so an
immense amount of pain misery
destruction and death is absolutely
guaranteed every year that we allow cars
to be on the road and we can take safety
precautions like we do we can minimize
the problem as much as possible but we
know we absolutely know just ask the car
insurance companies we know that there
will be around 30 to 35 thousand fatal
car accidents every single year now even
though we all know this
nobody ever suggests that all cars be
banned
and for the purposes of this
conversation I'm gonna put aside the
extremist environmentalists who advocate
for banning cars on the basis that
they're you know gonna kill the entire
world in 11 years
those people do but for an entirely
different reason nobody that I've ever
heard
advocates banning cars in order to stop
all these car accident deaths even
something like raising the driving age
to 30 that's a move that would save
thousands of young lives
and it's not nearly as extreme as
getting rid of all cars but that's not
seriously suggested or considered even
something like a mandatory federal
minimum speed limits of 40 miles an hour
for the most part nobody advocates that
so nobody advocates getting rid of cars
nobody advocates even less stringent
measures like raising the driving age to
30 lowering the the speed limit
significantly why is that well though
nobody would ever put it like this it's
because we've decided that 35,000 dead
people is a cost worth paying in order
to keep our cars all of that death all
of that pain all of those countless
lives destroyed it's all worth it we say
so that we can get from point A to point
B quicker again nobody would ever phrase
it like this and we don't like to think
of it like this but this is the
calculation there's no way around it if
you think that we should keep cars on
the road and we should keep driving
around then you are saying you are
absolutely saying that those 35,000 dead
people who are guaranteed the 30 or 35
thousand dead people that are guaranteed
next year in the coming year are worth
the cost that is what you are saying
anybody who really disagrees I mean
really disagrees and actually thinks
that that's not a cost worth paying
would be calling for the prohibition of
all motor vehicles yet
nobody is now you might argue that cars
save more lives than they take well and
I could see how you would try to argue
that how would a person in a medical
emergency get to the hospital as quickly
as they need to if we don't have
ambulances but it's at a minimum
debatable whether ambulance has saved
more people than car accidents kill I'm
not sure if that's true or not and
besides it a very easy solution is
available there we could ban all cars
except emergency vehicles and this would
save even more lives because now the
fire trucks and police cars and
ambulances can get around they don't
have to worry about congested highways
and cluttered streets and everything
else yet once again nobody argues for
that we've decided that the infringement
on our lifestyles and our liberties that
a motor vehicle ban would entail is not
worth the lives it would save you look
all across society and we find these
sorts of calculations being made Eve
even though we make them implicitly we
make them without thinking much about
them we are still making them in our
homes - in fact I have a personal story
related to this that I want to relay in
just one second but first let's check in
with Rock Auto you know in keeping with
the theme here if something goes wrong
with your car and you need to get it
fixed and you still need your cars to
work well what are you gonna do you
probably if you don't want to go to the
store maybe you can't depending on the
situation in your state that's why you
want to be able to order online and
because there's so many different types
of cars it's impossible to keep them all
stocked even if you do go into an auto
parts store that's once again why you
need rockauto.com and you have it
fortunately at your desk you carried
around in your pocket it's as easy as
that rockauto.com is everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks to live delivered directly
to your door rockauto.com always offers
the lowest prices possible rather than
change changing prices based on what
market will bear like a lot of
industries do that's not happening here
it's the same price for everyone why
would you choose to spend 30% 50% 100%
more for the exact same item that you
can get you know on online why would you
go into a store to pay more spend more
time and everything else now
rockauto.com also I should mention is a
family business serving auto car post
Auto Parts customers online for 20 years
and I think especially these days we
should all want to support small
businesses family businesses and that's
just yet another reason to go check out
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car truck right walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you so we make these
calculations all the time about risk
first reward a few days ago I was inside
and I had to run outside suddenly and
rescue my son who had been he had been
outside maybe for three minutes but if
you know if you have kids you know that
doesn't take him long to get themselves
into trouble so in the span of three
minutes he had got himself stuck about
20 feet up in a tree perched on a
precariously thin branch and was I went
up and even though the branches were
pretty even thinner for me and of course
I was fortunately able to get up and
bring him down now had I not gotten
there in time or had his sister not had
the wherewithal in the presence of mine
to come and get me like she did he might
have fallen and who knows what happens
when a kid falls 20 feet out of a tree
if he were to fall on his head break his
neck he would have died does that mean
that I'll never let my son play outside
in our yard unattended ever again no it
would certainly make him safer if I kept
him locked inside under our watch
watchful eyes at all times but we as
parents have decided that the risk not a
substantial risk but also not entirely
unsubstantial is a price worth paying in
order to give our children a little bit
of freedom and a chance to have some fun
and be normal children every
you open your front door and you tell
your kids go play there's a risk and
what you're saying even if you don't say
it out loud hopefully you don't is that
the risk of bodily injury or death that
is inherent in them going outside to
play is worth it for the benefit of them
simply being children and having some
fun now god forbid if my son did tumble
off that branch I'm sure I would have
wished that I had kept him chained to me
at all times and if a family member ever
dies in a car accident I would wish that
all cars had vanished from the earth
before that happened and if my parents
were to die of the coronavirus I would
probably wish that the entire economy
had been burned to the ground and
millions had made had been made
destitute to save them in fact someone
said to me yesterday well how would you
feel this was your child who had
coronavirus and what if your child died
of Corona by well if this is my child
yeah I would send the entire world into
a great depression I would make you
homeless and all your kids almost
probably to save my own child that's
what I would do for my own child but in
my grief and my my longing would I be
looking at these issues more rationally
and ethically or less the question is
should I approach life at all times with
the mentality of a grief-stricken man
desperate to preserve his loved ones
lives at any and all costs no matter
what it is that how I should always
approach things is that how we should
approach things or should we allow for
certain risks even risks that we know we
probably regret if tragedy were to
strike now the corona virus itself is
not like car accidents it's not like a
boy stuck in a tree but the ethical
question is essentially the same and
this is what the point I think Trump was
trying to make our cars and the positive
impact they have on our lives we say
even if we don't say it where´s we still
say our worth the 10 million people who
will die in them or because of them
across the globe over the next decade 10
million our children's fun and freedom
is worth the risk to their physical
health that must inevitably
accompanying now the balance could tip
the other way obviously there are many
fun things that my kids want to do that
I don't let them do because the risk is
too much and maybe if enough people died
in cars I don't know maybe if say five
million were perishing on our highways
in just in this country alone every
single year maybe we really would
consider banning them I don't know there
is a line somewhere I don't know where
exactly I don't think you do either
but apparently when it comes to cars
wherever that line is it is comfortably
above the 35,000 dead body threshold
that's not enough to make us even
consider banning cars so how many people
have to die before we even talk about it
100,000 a million I don't know so then
what about the coronavirus if our cars
are worth thirty five thousand dead
what is our economy worth what is our
way of life worth if the benefit of
having heavy chunks of metal flying
around a terrifying speeds outweighs the
substantial downside how do we weigh our
entire economy against the risk of an
out-of-control viral outbreak you know
if I were to what if I were to say right
now that I think 35,000 dead people from
the coronavirus is a price worth paying
to save our economy what if I were to
say let's open the economy up and you
know where's my line I think as long as
we we keep the death toll around 35,000
I'm okay with that now yes it may kill
many more than that it may kill fewer
that's not the point right now I'm
saying if I were to say that you would
probably call me a monster you would say
you're really not 35,000 people died
just for the economy
yet yet while calling me a monster you
have already signed on to that price
just for the minivan in your driveway
you have already made that calculation
and said yes I am that is a price I
think we should pay 35,000 dead people
on our highways fine now could the
minivan really be worth more by itself
than the minivan combined with your
house your job your food your retirement
savings everything else that will be put
on the line during an economic crash
if these shutdowns were to last for
months on end as some government
officials seem to indicate they will
clearly not we in fact it turns out
despite what people like New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo are saying we
should not destroy the economy and
embrace destitution just to save one
life we won't even commit to riding our
bikes to work for that so what would the
economy's destruction be worth would its
destruction be worth it to save 50,000
lives 100,000 a million I don't know the
answer but this is the question we're
asking and the conversation we have to
have as unsavory as it seems and once
again I don't know the answer I've
struggled with this as you know over
these weeks but it should be noted as
president Trump already did that the
people appalled by this conversation the
people say how dare you even think in
these terms they are participating in
the conversation whether they like it or
not every time they drive to the grocery
store they take part in the dialogue
even if they don't give their answers
out loud and that is the question we are
facing as I've been saying
potential worst-case scenarios on one
side of the other we've got the worst
case scenario of the coronavirus killing
many thousands or even millions of
people depending on who you listen to
worst case on the other end of the
spectrum if these shutdowns go on too
long and there are some who say maybe
they've already gone on too long as far
as the economy is concerned maybe that
maybe the damage is already a revocable
I don't know but on the other end of
spectrum worst case scenario is a
economic crash unlike anything we have
ever seen a Great Depression that Dwarfs
the last one millions destitute looting
rioting and everything else that is I'm
not saying that's going to happen it
could happen it is a worst-case scenario
and what we're doing is we're balancing
these two worst-case scenarios and we're
saying okay if we try to avoid this
worst-case scenario over here of the
economic crash yes you know that means
we get back to work and we take certain
precautions but still there's a risk of
more people dying from the coronavirus
well how many dead makes it worth it to
stave off the economic crash that's the
question the thing is if you say no no
we can't do that lets just stay locked
out as long as we need to well then
you're saying that this worst-case
scenario the economic crash is a price
you're worth you're willing to pay and
so I could ask you how many destitute
families are you willing to accept how
many would make it worth it to you or
how many would make it so that it's not
worth it anymore
are you willing to have 50 million
destitute families out on the street not
able to feed their kids in order to keep
these lockdowns going is that too much
okay well then 10 million I mean where
is your line I don't think we can hide
from this question and I think that's
what President Trump was trying to say
all right let's go to your news
headlines before we do if you haven't
had a chance yet to see some of our new
content called
all-access live you should head over to
daily wire comm check it out Jeremy
boring and ben shapiro kicked it off
last week and then we all did live
streams each day over at daly why
and we will continue all of this week at
8:00 p.m. 5:00 p.m. Pacific all-access
live is a lot more relaxed than a normal
programming you know the normal shows
and stuff that we do it's less focused
on bringing news and information it's
more of a conversation we're sitting
there talking to you and we've been
getting a lot of amazing messages from
our daily wired community during these
trying times and we can see they're
coming from a positive and heartfelt
place and I think that this live stream
then is not only good for the viewers
but it's good for us it's therapeutic
for us as well to be able to have these
conversations so this is a show intended
for our all-access members but during
this national emergency and time of
isolation we've opened it up to all of
our members and in doing so accelerated
the launch so please let us know what
you think of it and if you're around at
8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific tonight
then tune in I would I believe it'll be
me tonight doing the all-access show so
last time last week I did conclude our
all-access show by playing a musical
number on my banjo who knows what will
happen today I might have to even bust
out the kazoo because I am a kazoo
expert all right let's go to your
headlines
number one the Senate and White House
have agreed to a two trillion dollar
stimulus package there's a lot in the
bill obviously but focusing on what I
think is the most important thing here's
a reminder reading from CNN of how the
checks to individual Americans will work
under this plan it says under the plan
as it was being negotiated individuals
who are in $75,000 an adjusted gross
income or less would get direct payments
of $1,200 each with married couples
earning up to $150,000 receiving $2,400
and an additional $500 per each child
the payment would scale down by income
phasing out entirely at 99 thousand
dollars for singles and a hundred
ninety-eight thousand dollars for
couples without children so that's
that's the plan at least as on the
individual checks piece of it this to me
I'm sorry is a joke it two trillion
dollars spent and you're giving 1,200
bucks to some Americans which for most
will not even be enough to come close to
covering the bills and you're excluding
millions of American families because
they
made according to the government too
much money two years ago what if they
make less money now well they're out of
luck and what if they earn over the
threshold now but their family business
has been destroyed or they live in a
high cost of living area and so even
with that income level they're still
basically living paycheck to paycheck
what if a thousand other scenarios
doesn't matter no help for you that's
what the government says by the way
here's a question is this money gonna be
taxed I I don't know I don't know the
answer to that question I suspect that
it will be counted as income and so
it'll be taxed so in that case they're
gonna sent they're gonna they're gonna
send you back your own money which is
what these stimulus checks are it's your
money they're giving it back to you and
then they're gonna tax you on it so they
give you the check and then it tax time
next year they come back around they say
hey did you happen to get any checks
sent to you in addition to your your
regular paychecks I mean I don't know
did you get anything else because oh
yeah I did I got a stimulus check oh
cool what we're just gonna need a chunk
of that we're gonna need a little just a
little chunk of it but you gave it to me
in the first place what oh did we I
forgot all about that anyway so about
that chunk just a little chunk is what
we're gonna need meanwhile the White
House is now telling us that the total
stimulus effort the total thing
including this bill and other measures
will total six trillion dollars six
trillion dollars just to give you an
idea of how much money that is if you
were to stack it in one dollar bills it
would reach over 400,000 miles into this
guy enough to hit the moon you'd have so
much that you you could hit the moon and
then you'd have so much leftover on the
moon you could build another stack going
back to earth which is good because then
you're not stuck on the the moon you
could climb that stack by as far as the
physics and everything I'm not sure how
much that would work but but still
that's that's that's the amount of money
we're dealing with it is a lot of money
to put it mildly I wonder are we getting
to the point where you might as well
just give everybody a million dollars
spend 327 trillion dollars give
everybody a million bucks but
at what point does it not matter anymore
six trillion dollars is already more
money than actually exists on earth as
it is so when you get to the point where
you're spending more money than exists
on planet earth what why why even what's
the difference just mmm I so make a 300
trillion a quadrillion yeah
whatever I don't I think I'm in favor of
the stimulus checks to America's I
actually think it should be more but at
the same time with these shutdowns
continuing now for many more weeks it
seems like so we're closing up
businesses decimating the economy the
government spending six trillion dollars
passing that bill off on future
generations it we've got a recipe here
for something that is not good
economically number two Joe Biden has
basically disappeared over the last week
rather than rather than getting out
there maybe not out there you can't do
that but at least on TV being seen
making his case trying to show how he
would lead in a situation like this he's
been like locked in a basement somewhere
they're keeping him out of sight until
the last couple of days and now he's
finally showing up again we're seeing
him on TV and I think based on his
appearances we're starting to see why
they were hiding him in the first place
so let's let's watch this here's just
one one example watch this in hot topics
we just about Trump saying the
government would reassess the
recommended period for keeping
businesses shut and people at home are
you at all concerned as Trump said that
we cannot let the Cure be worse than the
problem itself we have to take care of
the cure that will make the problem
worse no matter what we have to take
care of the cure that will make the
problem worse no matter what take care
of the cure taking care of the cure will
make the problem worse no matter what
but
what is taking care of the cure mean it
sounds good it sounds like you want it
okay I'm taking care of the cure hey I'm
taking care of that cure like somebody
saying that what they mean is they're
gonna cure it right whatever the problem
isn't so you're saying that's gonna make
the problem worse curing the problem
will make it worse I don't get it I'm
I'm not even trying to be funny I really
don't even understand what he's even
driving it this isn't just stumbling
over your words this is a apparently
totally nonsensical statement and then
Nancy Pelosi yesterday also had her own
Joe Biden moment listen to this well I
do think that there is a whole concern
in our country that are forgiving tens
of billions of dollars to the airlines
that we could least have a shared value
about what what happens to the
environment but that is it
you know that is an excuse not a reason
for Senator McConnell go forward some of
the other issues like not fully
extending family medically not funding
food stamps I hope that will all change
in the next few hours but there are
issues that are central to the
well-being of America there is a whole
concern in our country that if we're
giving tens of billions of dollars to
the airlines that we could at least have
a shared value about what happens to the
environment have a shared value about
what happens to the environment we have
a shared value I don't understand what
that means either I don't I don't
understand it I don't know what these
people are talking about but the best
and brightest right here that we have
the best and brightest leading the way
but that makes me feel better in these
in these times dealing with one of the
one of the great crises that we've ever
faced as a nation and with that woman by
that I mean also the economic
devastation that they're causing right
now the whole thing right but it's just
good to know that these are the people
or making decisions all right number
three interesting report in The Daily
wire right now by Amanda presto Giacomo
she writes government policy and
guidance crafted in an effort to flatten
the curve of coronavirus related deaths
as large
been based upon an imperial college
london model headed by professor neil
ferguson the terrifying model shows that
as many as 2.2 million americans could
perish from the virus if no actions
taking peeking taken peaking in june
however that model is likely highly
flawed Oxford epidemiologist tsunaide
Chirag Gupta writes professor Gupta led
a team of researchers at Oxford
University in a modelling study which
suggested the virus has been invisibly
spreading for at least a month earlier
than suspected concluding that as many
as half of the people in the UK have
already been infected by kovat 19 if
this is the case fewer than one in a
thousand have been infected with Cova 19
become sick enough to need
hospitalization leaving the vast
majority with mild cases or free of
symptoms with so many in the UK and
potentially United States presumably
infected so called herd immunity could
kick into effect dramatically limiting
the number of deaths modeled by Ferguson
hen company the Financial Times explains
the Oxford study is based on a what is
known as a susceptibility infected
recovery model that that old canard
of Kovan 19 built up from case and death
reports from the UK and Italy the
researchers made what they argue as the
most plausible assumptions about the
behavior of the virus report continues
the modeling behave that brings back
into focus herd immunity the idea that
the virus will stop spreading when
enough people have become resistant to
it because they've already become
affected okay that's your positive side
of things interesting perspective there
number four we'll go to we'll go from
well try to keep a balance here right so
we've got the positive will go to the
negative nice balance between comforting
and terrifying reading from The Daily
Mail it says an intensive care
specialist has described how one person
with corona virus could infect up to
fifty nine thousand others as the virus
is more than twice as infectious as the
flu and we're not just talking about
people on spring break here this is dr.
Hugh Montgomery a professor of intensive
care medicine at University College
London explained how the virus could be
passed from one person to thousands as
he calls on Britain's to heed advice on
social distancing he says normal flu if
I get that I'm going to infect on
average about 1.3 at one point four
people if there was such a division
if those 1.3 or 1.4 people give it to
the next slot that's the second time it
gets passed on by the time that's
happened 10 times I've been responsible
for about 14 cases of the flu doc dr.
Montgomery went on to illustrate how
coronavirus is far more infectious than
the common flu with one person
potentially infecting 59 thousand others
under the same circumstances just based
on the exponential way that these things
are passed on so that's there's the
negative side of it as well two
perspectives I'm not going to tell you
which one to believe because I have no
idea number five an interesting notice
on the website for Planned Parenthood
Keystone
so that's Planned Parenthood of
Pennsylvania essentially and if you go
to the website is this is the notice
that that is opposed to there right now
it says to ensure the health and safety
of our patients staff and community
Planned Parenthood Keystone is
temporarily closed all of its health
care all of its health centers quote
unquote I'm adding the scare quotes for
family planning visits effective March
23rd 2020 at this time Planned
Parenthood stone is serving patients in
Allentown wilkes-barre Warminster
Redding York and Harrisburg for abortion
services only birth control starts and
renewals depo shots emergency
contraception UTI treatments vaginitis
rash or Legion and STI treatments will
be available via telehealth very soon
okay that's interesting
I think because we're told that abortion
is only although they say they say it's
3% of what a Planned Parenthood does
they tell us especially when we're
talking about the funding of Planned
Parenthood Planned Parenthood gets 500
million dollars a year in tax funding in
in welfare checks basically from sugar
daddy government and but we're told
that's okay because Planned Parenthood
they hardly do any abort its like 3% of
what they do right no no but yeah yeah
it adds up to three hundred and thirty
thousand abortions which means three
hundred thirty thousand dead children
every single year but it's only three
percents basically nothing they hardly
do any abortions
that's the arguments the spin the
propaganda that we're told but yet here
we are
and they're shutting everything down and
supposedly this is a facility that it's
a health facility and you would think
that's pretty essential and they do all
kinds of really important essential
health related things and yet at least
in their physical facilities they're not
offering any of that but abortions if
it's only 3% of what they do and it's
not even that important to their overall
business model as we're told
then why would they stop doing
everything but that I mean if you're a
business and you've got to cut things
back would you would you narrow things
down to only three percent of your
business the three percent that's so
much less important than everything else
you do I mean if anything shouldn't they
stop doing abortions and continue all of
the other allegedly essential healthcare
practices that they that they perform
the services they provide no but it's
said they stopped doing all of that and
they only do the abortions it would seem
like call me crazy but it would seem
like the reason they're only doing the
abortions is because actually that's
really all they basically do or that
that is it at a minimum that is actually
the the point of their organization and
everything else is peripheral everything
else is just an add-on that they tack on
at the end and so they can stop doing
all of that
but they're still gonna do the abortions
they keep the money coming in and their
business is still alive and humming and
going right along that's how it would
seem to me all right let's go to your
daily cancellation today we're canceling
marine Farooqi who is a feminist
lawmaker in Australia now you knew you
just knew the feminists would try to
make coronavirus about themselves you
knew they would because everything is
about them they can't help it and here
we are let us not forget that corvid 19
is a gendered crisis nurses nurse AIDS
teachers child carers and early
childhood educators aged care workers
and cleaners are mostly women they are
on the front line of this public health
crisis and carry a disproportionate risk
of being exposed to the virus let's also
not forget that not all homes are safe
places quarantine or self isolation at
home will put women and children at risk
women's advocates and domestic violence
experts are warning us the domestic
abuse increases during times of crisis
and I'm terribly worried that these
warnings have not been heeded by this
government that has long resisted
adequate funding for the needed
resources and refuges a gendered crisis
she says because everything is gendered
in the addled brain of a feminist even
as they say that gender is essentially a
social fiction like I said addled brain
but notice a few things a few things
first she says nurses nurse aids etc are
mostly women you notice who she left out
doctors surgeons they also I would argue
or on the front lines of this thing but
what about them well they're not
mentioned because they don't they don't
count because they're mostly men so
we're gonna forget about them but
secondly if the corona virus is picking
on one gender especially more than the
other
it's definitely men who are the primary
victim the vast majority of deaths from
the virus are male some figures suggest
that it's around 70% that the death rate
is 70% male at least that's the case in
Italy and across the board it's
certainly a majority of cases of the mo
severe cases the fatal cases are male
yet she's trying to make it into a thing
that's that's a victimizing women the
most this just shows you how feminism
works this feminist was able to take a
disease that mostly kills men and
turning into a crisis that mostly
affects women I mean it's extraordinary
next thing you know she's gonna be
telling us that prostate cancer is
mainly a crisis affecting women this is
the way it goes though when you buy into
a victim narrative and that's an and
that's the way you look at life and the
narrative is that women are victims and
men are not well then every situation
has to be seen through that lens which
leads to manifest absurdities like this
so miss Farooqi you are cancelled for
that reason now let's go to emails we
have a couple emails here I wanted to
get through as we wrap the show up this
and you've become a daily while remember
you could send emails to the mailbag
this is from James says dear Matt thank
you for your coverage of the Chinese
virus over the last few days I'm tired
of seeing the world brought to its knees
over a cold you seemed like you were
panicked a few days ago but I've settled
down that's that's great keep it up
see this is exactly the wrong way of
looking at this James I hate to
disappoint you the virus is not just a
cold it's a very serious disease highly
contagious high levels of
hospitalization deadlier than the few
flu these are all facts right so and
well I guess I should I mean that we
talked about the levels of
hospitalization as I just read during
the headlines we actually we don't know
exactly what the actual rate is when you
compare hospitalization rate to the
number of effective because we don't
know how many people are affected but we
do know that lots of people are going to
the hospital they just put it that way
okay and you can look at what's
happening in New York right now we see
what's happened in other countries now
so that those are facts does that mean
that we should shut the economy down
down indefinitely no I don't think so as
I've argued because it and I what I'm
trying to make this very clear
it's
not saying that we shouldn't shut the
economy down either we should get the
economy going again soon because the
virus isn't a big deal that's not my
argument that has never been my argument
what I'm saying is I'm afraid that the
cost is too great to bear and it might
not even achieve much anyway when it
comes to stopping or slowing the virus
what if what if it you know what if the
virus continues it seemed as it seems to
be doing and in places like New York it
continues to do continues to spread
rapidly and we stay locked down we
destroy the economy so now we have a
destroyed economy and we've still got
the virus to deal with or and if we're
not staying locked down until there's a
vaccine a year from now presumably even
the most extreme people in favor of a
lockdown would agree that eventually we
have to start back up again and what if
we start back up again in the virus
comes back with a vengeance now we've
got a destroyed economy and the virus
and we're less capable of dealing with
all of these things for me come to bear
in analyzing this and I'm saying that
destroying the economy is a mistake and
it won't be worth it because of the
human cost so I believe sooner rather
than later we need to get people back to
work so they can feed their families
while taking a number of precautions
instituting measures that I've outlined
over the last few days and these are not
measures that I came up with this is not
I'm not the first one to think of these
but there are a number of things we
could do we could open the economy while
still taking a number of measures
including if you're in favor of more
draconian measures by the government
there are draconian things you could do
even while getting the economy going
such as for example mandatory masks laws
for everybody that goes out in public
now I'm not saying I'd be in favor of
that I don't I don't know how you need
to produce a hell of a lot more masks in
order to do it I think we could do that
I don't know how you would enforce it
would people actually follow it these
are all questions but then you have the
same problem with a shutdown how do you
enforce that especially as weeks go by
and people are sick of it how do you
enforce it our people are gonna follow
it I think at a certain point they won't
anymore so you still have that issue
but you could do you know that that's it
that's it now I as far as masks go I
would be more in favor of being more
targeted where maybe certain industries
it's required that you have masks at
least for a time but then there are many
other things that you do to your
quarantine the nursing homes you people
that are especially vulnerable you keep
them home quarantine the elderly and and
anyone who's in that category but needs
a paycheck to survive what we can
continue to support them and we could be
more targeted in our approach that way
so when I what I am suggesting is just a
more targeted approach at the virus
while trying to keep the economy going
as much as possible to stave off a
depression and the destitution and
suffering that will come from that the
point is we cannot take the extreme of
let's keep everything locked down for
six months we can't go with that extreme
but we also can't go to the other
extreme that you're at and say this is
just a cold because that's not the case
either so you know I don't know the
solution nobody does
I don't want thousands of people to die
from this virus I also don't want our
economy to be destroyed and families to
be destitute there's got to be a path
that navigates those extremes or maybe
there isn't I say there has to be
there's got to be look at it there
doesn't have to be it's possible if
there is no path there is no good answer
but maybe there is and we have to look
for it right now we've bought in totally
to shut everything down Great Depression
be damned I'm saying let's not do that
let's actually look at all of our
options and try to be a little bit more
creative in the way we deal with this
all right let's go to Anna says hi Matt
thought I'd change the discussion from
the coronavirus to something else think
out what is your take on soulmates is
your wife your soulmate do we all have
one person out there who is made for us
it's a good question and Anna I do
believe in soulmates
soulmates would be two people who meet
on a foot fetish website pausing for
laughter so I apologize for that but it
is a pretty good pun you have to admit
that's a good pun anyway
the answer is no I don't believe in
soulmates I not in the case of one
individual who's out there in the world
who's the right person for you and is
waiting for you to find them I don't
believe in that is my wife my soulmate
yes because we're married and which we
chose to become soulmates that was a
choice we made which to me makes it even
more meaningful he wasn't like this was
written written in the stars and and so
I had to end up with my wife and we're
sort of a slaves of destiny or whatever
that's that's not how I see it I see it
as we both started our lives in
different states hundreds of miles apart
and we lived our lives and made choices
and went this way on that and there were
a million different choices we could
have made that would have taken us in
different directions we could have made
those choices we didn't there were there
were other people we could have ended up
with but we didn't you know we didn't
make that choice either and then we met
each other we made a choice to be
together and and because of that choice
and that free choice I think it makes it
so much more meaningful and once you
make the choice now you're committed
you've made an oath before God and now
you are soul mates so I wasn't my wife's
soul mate when I met her I was her soul
mate when I said I do and when she said
I do I think there's another thing about
this soul mate thing I think there's a
great danger in this mentality actually
and we see it play out in society over
and over again I'll tell you what the
danger is if you believe that there are
soul mates there's someone out there
that's made for you ahead of time and
all you have to do is go find them first
of all with all these quarantines that's
can be very difficult to do but more
importantly well what if you meet
somebody and you think they're your soul
mate and you marry them
then you discover that oh you know I
don't think they are my soulmate and
then you go to your job and you have a
co-worker and you say oh I think this is
my soulmate and that's how marriages are
destroyed and invariably what happens is
the person who says that oh yeah I made
the wrong choice I just met the right
person I'm gonna leave this per my
spouse in the dust even if I have kids
they're gonna leave them in the dust -
I'm gonna go with my real soulmate
invariably what do they find out they
find out that I don't know that person's
not my soulmate either I'll have to keep
looking five marriages later you know
destroyed families destroyed lives
that's where the soulmate thing takes
you I think but if it's true that there
are soulmates and that there is one
person out there who's made for you
destined for you then it is true that
you could end up with the wrong person
and then you could meet some other
person who's the right person and by
this way of thinking then it if you had
some way of knowing that this other
person is your soulmate then it would I
guess be right to leave your spouse for
this other person because this person
was made for you
this is who God or the universe or
whoever intended for you but that can't
be the case you know it can't be that we
were destined to leave a person who we
made a an undying vow and commitment to
it just it can't be and I don't I don't
think that's that's the case so your
soulmate is the person who you choose to
be here soulmate as long as they choose
you as well but thank you that was a
nice little nice little break from from
the coronavirus madness which we will
get back to tomorrow I'm sure and thanks
everybody for watching stay safe out
there
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor
Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there